[Music]
so what's this AI thing that you're
doing so basically there's this thing
called deforum I believe it's called
it's like it uses stable diffusion do
you know what stable diffusion is okay
you know what dolly is yeah like that's
a stable diffusion is like another one
of those but I think it's open source or
something and it's for video
yeah so they've taken that and we
basically with stable diffusion you can
upload an image you can use an image as
like a starting point yeah as a
reference and then the AI will create
another image based on that and you can
kind of weight it so that it'll create
something like if you want it to it'll
create something that's very very
similar to the original thing so what
this does is export you it exports a
video as a just a series of frames yeah
and then it'll run stable diffusion on
every single frame so every frame is a
little bit different exactly and so then
when you put them back together in
Premiere it looks like a video
oh so you have to export each frame yes
and then cut it all together yeah holy
[ __ ] yeah that's why I've I did it like
you know like 12 different times that's
why it like kind of Fades into the
cactus one yeah and it'll that's all
like different prompts that I was
writing and then I would run that on a
portion of the video and then I just put
them all together how long did I take
you
20 hours dude Jesus Christ like an
insane amount of time
and I haven't finished it yet I have to
finish it before Friday
what the video this part yeah I know but
I'm putting up the full video as like a
standalone thing yeah so like you're not
done with the video and you're putting
it on Friday yeah but dude you're really
playing with fire here it's only Tuesday
it's Wednesday with the time Wednesday
when the episode comes out it's only
Wednesday I got two days yeah so I'm
stoked on that I'm very stoked and then
I'm just gonna keep releasing music I
think like it's like try and go for one
song a month and just see if I can I
will say I'm very against like uh
YouTubers making music you know yeah
you're very good at it the production is
very good the video is always very funny
I'm not trying to dick right or anything
yeah hop off
no but the production is very who does
all the production are you using the
same guys well this like the stuff that
we did as TMG yeah that's like mostly
Christian Spock did a couple songs for
us like he did stay safe yeah and uh but
and that's that's like one of my
favorite songs but like the rest of it
was Christian you know it's because of
like the combo everything it's not me
yeah like I'm not very good at making
music that's why I want to keep doing it
on my own because I want to get good at
it on my own like I would feel really
good if I could have a song a solo song
that would get a bunch of streams you
know yeah that would be a cool that's
like a cool goal for me are you doing
but like as TMG it's like Christian's
amazing the wall is amazing so like
everything together like the songs just
really worked you know do you perform
them live at all are you doing concerts
or the only time we ever performed well
we did music like on our tour but it was
like just we had a song about sucking
around dicks I remember so we would
perform that and then we had a couple
other songs that we wrote just for the
show but we never like did a you know
like a music show because we're like
what the [ __ ] are we we're gonna be 30
years old dude look at this like book
The look at Vonda and pretend that we're
like up and coming music artists we're
not like no it would have to be an
experience yeah exactly you have to be
like Lonely Island goes on tour they
perform music but I've never been to one
of their shows and I imagine it's
probably a decent amount of comedy in
there too yeah dude you know who's a a
great example for you guys is Akon
he his set I saw him in Vegas at this
vessel which was a terrible Festival by
the way
um he did a set in Vegas and each song
was a setup for another song so he was
basically doing stand-up wait what do
you mean so basically he would be like
oh man you know I [ __ ] around and then
I got locked up and then he would go
into locked up okay and then the second
song after that he's like you know
what's the first thing I do out of jail
and then played The Lonely Island like I
Just Had Sex dude it was one of the best
sets I've ever seen it's pretty funny
that's what you guys got to do yeah
that's I imagine that's what we would do
if we ever did music it would be like a
certain amount of you know roasting the
crowd and stuff like that yeah maybe
we'll do it one day I don't know but
dude I all like all I know is I gotta
see you DJ that song and I'm gonna be on
so much Molly yeah
because I gotta experience it to the
full potential yes dude and you're gonna
be the front row yep grind your teeth
yep and going down I'm gonna look right
at you and go nightmare nightmare
nightmare
now that video I feel like would [ __ ]
you up if you're on drugs
yeah yeah they have no I would not want
it is like pretty creepy it is pretty
scary just like the clips that you like
let's watch your back real quick there's
one that really [ __ ] me up it was like
a girl in it yeah her yeah that's me
really yeah and it's so funny I did this
one like I ran I ran it on the entire
video the entirety of this video right
took 10 hours to process and the prompt
I use it was you know a bunch of like
artistic words and then it was like you
can specify an artist if you want it in
their style so what I'll do is I'll just
go on Reddit and see what other people
are using for their prompts I don't know
any artists so I just like copy them
from other people's prompts right yeah
and so I use these three artists that I
found and I guess like they do like
Asian art so the whole thing I was Asian
all right cool that's a cool thing I
probably can't use any of these clips
why did you do that so did you when you
typed in these prompts did you type
anything like [ __ ] up I mean like the
the one that the main one I use was like
acid acid trip mushroom trip
psychedelic hallucination this was like
a space one
that was like I used like I look like
Luke Skywalker sort of because I and
like that thing in the back looks like a
look like a little honey that doesn't
that look like a whatever
like the big robots called that uh A.T
Walker yeah yeah that looks like that
right it was all like Star Wars theme
that part no Star Wars at all did you
have you ever typed in anything [ __ ]
up
like what Cody go naked or something no
have you why do you want to see that so
bad no I'm just curious
have you I haven't talked about it yet
but no I did see a tweet I sent a tweet
over to OV basically it was like when
people get a platform like dolly or
whatever they immediately go into porn
porn yes yeah and that's why I'm so
scared when robots come out because
they're just gonna try to [ __ ] them yeah
any way possible oh yeah that's why
there should be a band now yeah you
can't have sex with them yeah we already
try to [ __ ] robots when I mean like a
dildo that's a form of a robot yeah like
a library yeah fleshlights yeah stuff
like yeah like there's like a I remember
like yeah one time there was someone had
posted some like code that would like
what was it
I forget but it was [ __ ] up it was a
way of having sex in VR basically
it was like it attached to a dildo oh
it's like blue it's like connected to
Wi-Fi or something yeah but it would
like sync up with the porn that you were
watching that's
disgusting
yeah I was messed up I was like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ like and you did it you
tried it I know you saw it I don't know
yeah no I did not um so there's this AI
space thing oh yeah so what is this I
saw it earlier on the drive here but
basically
obviously she has huge knockers or
whatever right immediately they're just
like pregnant pregnant now
the AI didn't like the space helmet in
the first place but now it's corrected
another space woman
yeah so giant yeah this is the funniest
part about like being on the stable
diffusion subreddit is like a lot of
people will post images of women like
this and they'll be like finally getting
better at making faces
and it's like it's like these women that
are sitting there and they have gigantic
boobs every single time and it's like
people are like let me see your prompt I
know that there's like an entire section
of this that's you know defining how big
their tits are
so then
so yeah wait scroll down so someone
replied to this yeah and was like to
make a pregnant demanding pregnant
but now I kind of want to see it
just out of curiosity
it's just funny like this person doesn't
know that they can just
do it themselves yeah
demanding that someone else I don't
understand the AI but I need to see
pregnant right now now please please I
will say AI is scary for like uh
designers like we're talking about this
at Market just like pretty soon it's
gonna give designers a run for their
money well I mean I think like the
designer kind of becomes a curator the
yeah the narrator yeah like it just kind
of feels like prompt writing is its own
thing now yeah and I feel like anyone
that's good at design and has an eye is
going to be able to guide the AI to make
something cool already people are
writing plugins for Photoshop that uses
stable diffusion so you could just like
pull in a picture of a tree and then run
stable diffusion on it and it'll create
its own tree wait what are we typing in
my body my temple t-shirt graphic there
it is I hate I hate how none of them can
like do English yet but it looks like
English but it's not and it [ __ ] me up
every time I go back to that one
like dude we should actually print this
shirt because people will be like it
looks like a meme and it would throw
people off because it'd be like oh what
does your shirt say oh my God what is
yours why isn't there taking forever to
figure it out yeah remind me Smith's
markets have that
oh yeah
where'd you get that from